hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime uproar and if you thought
that the previous chapter was rough on
bakugo and the heroes it only gets way
way worse the heroes were beaten and
humiliated and they're trying their best
just to stay alive long enough for Deku
to arrive at this rate Deku might find a
bunch of dead bodies by the time he
finally gets there and we need to talk
about it you guys know what to do leave
a quick like and comment right now to
support the video in that YouTube
algorithm and of course subscribing and
hitting that notification Bell is a
completely free way of directly
supporting the channel finally this
video will contain Boku no hero manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned last time we saw
that bakugou was in serious
life-threatening danger as shigaraki
approached him with the intention to
both humiliate him and kill him due to
the fact that bakugou was already
injured at this point it was practically
impossible for him to fight back or get
away so his only hope was that he would
be rescued by the other Heroes with the
pro Heroes on the scene indisposed the
only ones who rushed to help bakugou
were the strongest hero students The Big
Three Sun eater nejire and of course
Medio in the latest chapter we see
shigaraki walking up to bakugou and
casually stepping on his head he asks
where Deku is because he knows the Deku
was supposed to be there and he's hoping
that Deku will arrive soon as we know
shigaraki slash all for one need Deku to
be there in order to try to steal one
for all from him which means that they
are prepared to do whatever it takes to
draw Deku out shigaraki then hilariously
uses his toes to pull bakugou up by the
hair he then tosses him up in the air
and grabs him by the throat I mean this
isn't just beating up bakugo this is
straight up flexing on him shigaraki
says that he plans to kill bakugou and
then present his dead body as a present
to Deku since Deku became enraged when
shigaraki seriously injured bakugou back
in jakku the villain knows that he can
use bakugou and his potential death to
Rattle Deku and wage psychological
warfare against him shigaraki then talks
about how bakugou grew up watching all
might heroics and he probably thought
that he too would one day be able to
compare to all mine but it's now time
for bakugou to face the dark true no
matter how hard he tries he will never
compare to all might and he will always
be living in deku's Shadow and wow man
this type of talk really emphasizes the
fact that all for one is in control of
shigaraki's body at the moment and not
shigaraki himself I say that because all
for one is known for waging this type of
psychological warfare and mocking his
opponents in battle in order to destroy
them mentally and what he is doing to
bakugou right now is highly calc
calculated he knows exactly who bakugou
is how much he idolizes almight and how
much he hates the idea of living in
deku's Shadow at the same time he also
knows how much Deku cares about his
friends and classmates so he knows that
he can use bakugou against Deku he can
potentially get Deku to lose focus or to
let his anger Cloud his judgment which
would provide the villain with an
important tactical Advantage one moment
of weakness on deku's part is all that
all for one needs to steal one for all
and that is exactly what the villain
intends to do he is planning to exploit
deku's weaknesses which are his desire
to save everyone and especially his
friends in order to get his hands on one
for all but before shigaraki can choke
the life out of bakugou Baku is saved by
nej Sun eater and Meteo who attempt to
outmaneuver shigaraki using teamwork and
also using the unique properties of
their three quirks sonider even tries to
poison shigaraki using scorpion toxin
but shigaraki laughs it off as his body
literally manifests a mouth into place
on his arm where he was stung and that
mouth then straight up spits the poison
right out of the body as shigaraki's
mutations begin to overwhelm Sun eater
shigaraki explains that his body is now
constantly changing and adapting but
while shigaraki was focusing on fighting
off nejireh and Sun eater Meteo managed
to sneak up on him grab bakugou and
throw him to safety shigarakida notices
Meteo and says that he remembers Meteo
from jakku Medio then formally
introduces himself as the hero Le
million Meteo seems to think that
shigaraki's destructive Tendencies come
from the fact that he never had any
friends and shigaraki's like what but as
Meteo is lecturing the villain about
friendship he is actually planning out a
strategy to keep shigaraki at Bay until
Deku arrives Meteo knows that with his
strength alone he cannot hope to win
again shigaraki but he plans to use the
energy from negidesk work which has been
wrapped around his arm to deliver a
powerful point-blank hit on shigaraki as
Meteo uses permeation to move through
shigaraki's mutation in order to reach
the main body and deliver his attack we
see that genus has successfully pulled
bakugo to safety and is trying to
determine the extent of the student's
injuries genus tells bakugo to let him
sew up the wound on his arm and he also
says that shigaraki's power is in a
whole different dimension now so bakugou
doesn't need to beat himself up over the
fact that he lost but bakugou isn't
listening instead bakugou is carefully
watching the battle between shigaraki
and the big three and he seems to be
trying to get a handle on shigaraki's
fighting style bakugou appears to be
trying to find the patterns in
shigaraki's movements in order to come
up with an effective way to counter them
genus is shocked that even after all the
damn damage that he took bakugou is
still not finished and he is still
trying to find a way to contribute to
the fight and that is how this chapter
ends Deku is still M.I.A we still don't
know what exactly is going on with all
for one's original body but horikoshi is
definitely hinting that Deku will have
to arrive at the UA soon because if he
doesn't we will likely witness some
major deaths on that Battlefield things
are getting bad but before we go any
further I have to once again express my
utmost respect for bakugou in this
situation and in the fight in general
all for one slash shigaraki is clearly a
monster and even though bakugou is also
strong and even though he has improved a
lot since jakku he simply doesn't stand
a chance against shigaraki in a
one-on-one match-up that's just the way
it is being the cocky and fiery guy that
he is this is not easy for bakugou to
accept and if that wasn't bad enough the
villain is also talking him constantly
in a very cruel and calculated way
calling him the very thing that bakugou
is determined not to be a side character
who just lives in the shadow of Deku and
yet bakugou didn't lose his cool he
didn't freak out and he didn't give up
even against overwhelming odds even
though he is severely injured he is not
worried about getting medical help or
evacuating from the battlefield instead
bakugou is carefully watching shigaraki
in order to find an opening in his
technique even now after everything he's
been through bakugou is trying to find
the villain's weakness this really shows
how far Baku has come and how much he
has matured he is now able to control
his emotions even in overwhelmingly
stressful situations and he is able to
be a team player instead of trying to do
everything by himself and freaking out
if things don't go his way I know we're
at a point in the story where there are
a ton of Epic fights going on and it's
easy to focus on that but we can't
forget to agree appreciate some of the
crazy character development that has
been going on here especially with
Endeavor and bakugo so what is bakugou
going to do here is he going to figure
out something important about
shigaraki's fighting style something
that could give an advantage to the
heroes clearly bakugou isn't at full
strength at this point he has been
seriously injured and he can't expect to
beat shigaraki on his own but if he
could work together as a team with the
big three and the other Heroes maybe
they can find a way to buy enough time
for Deku to arrive can Meteo and the big
three hold their own against shigaraki
for long enough or is someone going to
die before decorize as things stand I
think that Deku has to appear very soon
because things are not looking good for
the heroes they may be able to buy a
little bit more time using whatever
bakugo seems to be planning but sooner
or later someone will be killed by
shigaraki I really hope we get to see
Deku in the next chapter because the
suspense sense of what is going on with
him is freaking intense what do you guys
think are we going to see Deku soon or
is horikoshi going to continue teasing
us with his arrival also will Deku make
it on time to save everyone or is he
going to find a grim present from
shigaraki when he does finally arrive if
someone ends up getting killed before he
gets there who do you think it will be
let me know down below if you guys
enjoyed this Boku no hero breakdown and
you want to see more in the future leave
a quick like and comment it really helps
with that YouTube algorithm and of
course if you're new to the channel or
maybe you watch our videos but you just
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a quick favor and subscribe and
hit that notification Bell to turn on
all notifications it is a completely
free but very important way of directly
supporting the channel you can also hit
me up on Twitter and Instagram at anime
uproar I want to give a big thank you to
all of our anime outpro patrons for
making videos like this one possible
special thank you to our the one
Frontier patrons the ones who stand
above all other clans including Alpha
Sigma Pate hefa The Toasted Qi Cory
McGowan big Buddhist and Jeremy pontier
and I can't forget all of our Pro Hero
tier patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh Angel Cruz Alicia Octor fat
boy games kaido might be a duck olivania
and Anime s kodam if you guys enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value for you consider supporting us on
patreon or here through YouTube
memberships even a single dollar helps
and it means a lot to us as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see ya Space Cowboys